there's a prior topic on the show that
we've discussed frequently although not
so much in the last year or two and that
topic is gay conversion therapy it's
also sometimes known as ex-gay third
therapy it's sometimes known as
reparative therapy and the idea of
ex-gay therapy is that people who
believe that they are gay or have been
living what the homophobic right calls a
gay lifestyle they simply need to have
therapy to quote cure that or to change
their sexual orientation what is at
issue with that is of course that people
don't choose their sexual orientation
people do choose their religion that's
certainly a self-professed but a sexual
orientation is not so the concept of a
conversion sort of like you would
convert from one religion to another
doesn't really make any sense
often these ex-gay therapists aren't
even actually therapists that's another
issue it's often religious treatment in
nature and the term treatment is even a
concern here often the ex-gay therapy is
itself abusive sometimes physically
sometimes sexually and the big news now
is that prominent gay conversion
practitioner I don't even want to call
him a therapist david matheson has come
out as gay himself which will not come
as a shock to many people in the
audience he put up a statement on his
facebook page a few days ago where he
said not that i would excuse myself but
any shortcomings I had as a therapist
came from too narrow a view of what
emotionally healthy can look like they
came from my own homophobia and narrow
mindedness I am truly sorry for those
flaws and the harm they have surely
caused some people and I'm sorry for the
confusion and pain my choice may be
causing other others he's even framing
his own coming out as gay as a choice
which I guess the the decision to
publicly state that he's gay is a choice
but of course being gay is not a choice
and so there are multiple tragedies here
but one tragedy is that he was married
to a woman for
34 years he ruined people's lives with
his homophobia and so-called therapy and
he is gay himself that's a tragedy for
everyone involved is a tragedy he
couldn't live his life as the person he
truly is it's a tragedy that he ruined
so many people's lives with his
so-called conversion therapy uh now he's
also a Mormon and he blames a lot of the
homophobia his homophobia on the Mormon
Church now that I believe the Mormon
Church is homophobic but blaming it just
on the church gets him out of criticism
that he still deserves he not all
Mormons are ex gay therapists that is
still something that he chose to do so
it's great that he came out but then the
biggest tragedy at the bottom of this is
that he still seems to think that this
so-called ex-gay therapy is legitimate
because he also added in his facebook
statement about this what you can take
from this is that my time in a straight
marriage and in the ex-gay world was
genuine and sincere and a rich blessing
for me to me I remember most of it with
fondness and gratitude for the joy and
growth it caused in me and many others
he's still pretending or believes that
ex-gay therapy is legitimate and good
and that it caused joy and growth for
the people that he interacted with as an
ex-gay therapist so this is I mean I
guess it's good in a sense that he can
now live as the person he is it seems as
though he's getting out of ex-gay
therapy but he still is touting the idea
that it's a good thing fortunately if we
want to find like a silver lining in
this entire thing ex-gay therapy
reparative therapy has been banned for
minors in fifteen states in fifteen
states including some of the highest
population ones like California and
Illinois and New York even if the
parents want to send the kid to ex-gay
therapy it's illegal to send minors to
it now our church is finding ways to get
around this or the religiously
affiliated ex-gay therapists figuring
out ways to get around this yes of
course they are but strictly speaking
it's still a success
the bad part is that it's unfortunately
still legal for adults everywhere and
for children in 35 states so progress
has been made
not nearly enough and you know the every
time the entire homophobic people are
actually gay thing comes up it's
important to just remind everybody that
most people who are homophobic are not
gay right and it actually doesn't even
really matter if they are homophobia is
something we can activate and argue
against regardless of whether the people
who are homophobic are doing it because
they are resenting and trying to repress
their own sexuality or because they just
think hey the Bible says I should be
homophobic so I am of course there are
some people who are using their
homophobia as a way to hide their
homosexuality of course that happens
it's not most people and I think that
sometimes the the pro LGBT rights groups
will go a little far with the memes and
the jokes about everybody who's
homophobic actually being gay I don't
think we really gain that much from it
but certainly there's no doubt that
there have been dozens of prominent
homophobes who were gay or bisexual so
much more work to be done 15 states have
at least done something good here